Let's go next to our old friend.
Oh, Okafor from the 5 1 3.
Hey, are you there?
Yeah.
Wow.
Thank you so much for that shout out, of course.
Hey, what's the correct pronunciation of your
first name?
I know you go by.
Oh, because it may be tough for some people
to pronounce, but how do you say it?
So it's actually only some do.
Okay, for.
So, I mean, small story, like my parents are
actually from Nigeria, but I was actually
born here.
Right.
Got it.
Very good.
OK.
OLISA Medawar.
I think I got it.
Yeah, why I was actually perfect, but yeah,
I just wanted to talk a little bit about the
progressive movement because a couple of weeks
I've been a little bit concerned because,
you know, with everything with Bernie Sanders
dropping out of the race and endorsing Joe
Biden and, you know, his supporters turning
on him like I do, I feel like the progressive
movement at this very moment is in disarray.
And I was just wondering what your thoughts
are on what's going on right now.
So here here's what I'm going to lean towards
in the interests of cause.
Remember, oh, I want to remove Trump in November.
And I think I don't want to play a role in
dividing the left.
I want to unite the left as much as possible.
So here's my view.
The world of the Twitter, read it online,
left during the primary, made it seem like
the Bernie wing of the Democratic electorate
was bigger than it actually is.
And in the end, when it came to votes, Biden
got almost 3 million more votes than Bernie
so far.
So what we learned was some of these ideas
are overrepresented if you pay too much attention
to read it and Twitter and the Internet.
My instinct is and we're seeing it with our
callers today where we had, you know, a Yangs
supporter who's voting, Bernie, a socialist.
Who's voting Bernie.
I'm sorry.
Who's voting Biden?
Socialist is what?
Voting Biden and a former Bernie supporter
who is voting Biden?
My instinct is that the progressive movement
is not really very divided.
I think that those who want to be loud and
boisterous and say, Joe's got to come for
my vote, my vote's not a blank check.
I don't know anybody.
And I know all this stuff.
I think they're being way louder online than
they actually are in the electorate.
I think most Bernie supporters, probably 90
percent, 88 to 90 percent are going to vote
for Biden.
The question is, will the 10 percent that
don't flip the election?
I don't know the answer.
Gotcha.
Yeah, that's pretty much all I had.
And the last thing I wanted to say is that
I was a Bernie Warren guy and I am 100 percent
on board with Noam Chomsky and Bernie Sanders
that we must vote for Joe Biden and that we
must defeat Donald Trump as well.
All right.
There we go.
OLISA Medawar Okafor, I hope I got that correct.
Really appreciate your call.
You.
Great.
Have a great one.
All right.
Take care.
Great to hear from them.